[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's uh jaylen rose friend of the show
played in a couple of uh national title
games lost to duke lost to north
carolina
and that's not the way to bring it up
when i well welcome jaylen
uh who were you rooting for between duke
and north carolina or rooting against
good morning my brother is that a trick
question everybody know i'm rooting
against duke first second third fourth
and fifth
no accident
were you rooting for carolina or just
rooting against duke
i think the latter i think when i met cj
mccullum for the first time at the 15th
seeded lehigh knocked off the number two
seeded
duke blue devils i gave him the biggest
hug he was just looking at me like i
don't even know you
you gotta say
i was like thank you i saw the i saw the
carolina team in new york city they were
here for the um acc tournament and after
they beat duke during the uh
the the acc tournament i thanked him
then thank y'all thank y'all i never
know that they playing for the first
final four in the first time
when did you start hating duke
but i want this to start off with i do
have a lot of respect for coach k and
all of that good stuff and uh i do
recognize greatness i am owen flora
against the duke blue devils and yes uh
christian later bobby hurley grant hill
they do own me so let me just say that
first and foremost
in all honesty um
uh i started hating duke when they
started um being really good
and they started beating all of the
teams that i rooted for
like i idolized unlv i cut it apart down
the middle of my head like larry johnson
and kenny anderson like i had a fake
gold tooth in my mouth like lj i was
left-handed
like stacy augmented greg anthony
anderson hunt went to my high school
detroit southwestern he was the final
four mvp
when they beat duke i was in his
basement watching the game when they
lost i never thought the next year i'd
be playing against duke so i got it
honest i truly got it honest
did you think about going to unlv
i did i took a few visits
i took uh
at that time you normally took visits
where you saw local stars also have
success
so i took a visit to syracuse because
derek coleman was there
um steve smith was at michigan state
took a visit there
and obviously unlv will anderson hunt
absolutely and tart the shark rest in
peace i love him you know one of his
favorite lines was when the ncaa get mad
at kentucky they put cleveland state on
probation that's so true
that's so true
you know the nil should be named after
tarkir sharp but but definitely took a
visit and definitely looked up to that
unlv team
how wild did the recruiting visits
turn out
so like uh what's the statute of
limitations you're good yeah you know
um
here's the thing right so if you're
recruiting me your goal is to show me a
good time
and if i'm a teenager and i'm coming to
your college campus
how can i show you a good time
only so much
like
architecture you can show me like this
is
you know
the library
arts and crafts building and look at the
facility right here look at this locker
room as a matter of fact that could be
your locker right there and then you
know you meet with the academic advisors
and they take you to a nice lunch and
all of that but you're like i'm still a
high school trying to be a college kid
like where's the real fun at
and then they turn you over to the
players at that point and then you have
a couple of chaperones or hosts and
obviously you try to touch base prior so
they can kind of see what you're
interested in you know certain beverages
that you might like or you know places
that you might like to go or music that
you like to hear that type of thing got
to make sure that it's a shared a shared
fun experience because you want the
recruit to sign the national letter of
intent
who's a number one seed when it comes to
entertaining
[Laughter]
the number one seed oh well you i heard
you mentioned wilt chamberlain as the
final four mvp even though his team lost
like he he's the number one overall seed
no
school schools that uh number one seed
uh oh um
how how could you not how could it not
be to run in rebels yeah
like how could it not be the running
rebels and they play in vegas like like
think about this when your recruiting
trip
has you in the casino that's different
it's just different well not many
recruiting trips where you also might
need bail money
or or you had a kind of relationship so
you don't have to worry about that yeah
we're talking to jaylen rose uh nba
countdown analyst co-host of jalen and
jacoby
uh anthony davis uh you know marvin play
anthony davis anthony davis had this to
say he just got back they lost to uh
denver yesterday and he said this after
the game
now there's no moral victories
in his league you know especially with
us
the whole world want to see us lose
be honest so um
but
i mean my job is to be on the floor help
these guys win
is the whole world out to get the lakers
no that's just what the expectations
that come with being a part of a story
franchise he understood that that's why
he wanted to leave new orleans to go
join lebron in la
and ultimately win a championship
but also that same fan base and those
same expectations to help you get the
17th championship
are the ones that the fans hope that you
can play more games than you missed this
year and that's what happened with
anthony davis and so when you look at
the standards
get a magnifying glass when you get a
chance to look at the standards to find
a lake you know like
as somebody that has been around this
league my entire life like this is
to have the level of talent on their
roster lebron is flirting with the
scoring title and playing at an elite
level at this point of his career
anthony davis still a top 10 player and
say what you want to say about russell
westbrook shooting he's still a
productive player
when you have those three guys in
uniform
and you're one of the worst teams in the
western conference like that's just
unacceptable and so it's not that people
want to see them lose it's that people
happy that they now get a chance to beat
them and kick them when they down that's
different who plays worst defense
brooklyn or the lakers
wow six in one hand half and another
um
one has lebron playing a lot of minutes
after five and the other has k.d quasi
playing a lot of minutes after five in
theory
i would say uh
you gotta say the lakers you gotta say
the lakers like they're just so bad
um defensively that and the body
language says a lot and it's from each
of the players it's when somebody misses
a layup or somebody does a bad pass you
know he had one guy trotting back and
then the other team just flying high and
mighty trying to trying to beat down the
purple and gold so i would have to say
the lakers are the worst d there was a
stat that i had here jalen i'm curious
how you would react to this 37 different
players have recorded triple doubles
this this year
that's tied for the most in the last 40
years
how do we get to that point where triple
doubles are commonplace
well a triple-double
used to have more impact on the game
because the score was lower
first off
so like there was a a period of time
when like the big o the legend was
putting up triple double records and i
as a player thought that they would
never be taken down like the high score
in a video game and then i saw great
players like magic come through the
league i was like if magic doesn't do it
it'll never happen if jason kidd never
does it it'll never happen
and so
what now has taken place is the the game
has gotten shorter like you have guys
that like in in just think about this in
houston russell westbrook was playing
basically power forward and center
we're talking about lebron now playing
five a guy like draymond green is six
for seven but he can guard center so the
game is shorter which means you have
more skilled players on the floor first
off so that mean you have more guys that
can actually dribble pass and shoot and
today's player
is more skilled than the players of the
past and i mean like shooting with range
shooting off the dribble
but the pace of play
and players being
shorter
lineups being shorter like just think
about this
when you look at a team in the 90s look
at the scoring champions they were
basically all sinners
david robinson
in the top 10 david robinson patrick
ewing akeem olajuwon
shaquille o'neal they were all sinners
and so they all have power forwards
horace grant
charles oakley oh distort the list goes
on and on and on
and so you had guys that were designated
to do things besides score and so now
everybody's out there designing the
score score score score score shoot
shoot shoot shooters early in the shot
clock is possible
that's the other thing you're not
exhausting possessions you watch a game
now somebody get a rebound dribbler
cause half court shoot it from the hash
mark with 22 seconds to go on the clock
and so
those are a few of the factors that have
now made the triple-double seem
like it doesn't have the same impact on
the box score but it does depending on
who's doing it that's why the joke
that's why the joker might have a chance
to win back-to-back mvp because his
triple doubles dan they are impactful
because he's a five out there shooting
threes and basically leading the league
and assists on one of the league leaders
and assists so he's been a joy to watch
this year
when they're all done when we these
careers let's say 15 years down the road
greek freak steph's done
embiid uh kd
who's in the top ten
out of out of that group somebody's
going to get into the top 10 which means
somebody comes out of the top ten
or well maybe you don't think that
somebody's gonna get in the top ten
so i i love this topic because
um
being born in the early 70s and being
around the game for my entire life
it's important to me to always have a
perspective and appreciate the players
of the eras they get
left out get lost because they weren't
around with social media or youtube or
whatever
and so for me like the first four or
five
basically are like iron clad
and the reason why i say that is because
they've accomplished things that no one
else will be able to accomplish to
remove them from this slot yeah michael
jordan six championships six finals mvps
two separate repeats
kareem abdul-jabbar six championships
six mvps all-time leading scorer to
lebron passing them unstoppable
trademark skyhook
bill russell 11 championships in 13
years dominated the boards play defense
like nobody has ever done like
those three people have accomplished
things
that i don't believe somebody else
that's going to play this game is ever
going to accomplish the things i just
said so to me those those human beings
are ironclad
i used to have like now a second tier so
lebron has entered that tier magic
johnson has entered that tier kobe
bryant larry bird tim duncan
shaquille o'neal and this just off the
top of the dome i know i'm gonna forget
somebody
um
but i it's tough to me to think that
kevin durant
is going to surpass any of the players i
just mentioned
he could but i i i
steph curry
they still have more work to do dan
that's what i would say both of those
guys still have more work to do giannis
i believe he
all three of those guys will be flirting
with it how about that to your point
they'll be flirting between the
conversation of eight or nine
and like 13 or 14.
though those guys will when when it's
when their career is in to be a part of
that conversation
but i don't think they'll like
crack like the top five or six
i don't know if i ever told you this i
grew up in cincinnati
i saw your dad play
um
when the people these stories when the
pistons
well see i was a big dave bing fan
godfather the legend i love dave bing
but
your dad
he might average 21 that year and 1972
71-72
and uh
i just remember
he was his back court you know i just
watched dave bing but your your dad your
dad could put up some points there
thank you i appreciate that and i'll
never forget one time i was in los
angeles it was like the mid 90s and i
never truly saw this i was watching like
uh
nba channel and it ended up being a 1972
all-star game and and i can't lie this
is actually sad
um but but it's true like hey i didn't
think that he might be in the game and b
i was watching the game and didn't stop
until i saw will and then i saw jerry
west then i saw dave bing
and then i saw my father jimmy walker
and then i actually started watching the
game true story while clyde frazier all
of them were part of that game so
historic time definitely and uh he
rubbed elbows with the greats how old
were you when you were watching your dad
in the all-star game
i was in the league then i was probably
like
22 oh watching the old clips oh okay i'm
i'm thinking you're watching your dad in
the all-star game when it was actually
happening so you're just oh yes yeah
correct i i was yeah i wasn't fortunate
enough to uh
to to to be around uh any of his nba
action what was his number 24 24 was his
number
yes and and for any uh youngster or any
person out there that you know doesn't
see eye to eye with a parent
or a sibling or whatever and you hope to
try to make it right make it right and
one of the things i did out of spite dan
is because his number was 24 i wore
number 42 in high school kind of like as
a a motivation that he would one day
know my name and i would one day um make
it to the nba
yeah
heavy stuff
that's why i changed it when i got to
college it was too heavy
i was like lebron when i got to
miami i didn't want to be the villain
i need a phone number
you
know yeah
do you still have
your uniforms
i have a couple i do uh
42 in high school we were national
champs i do have one or two from
michigan i do have a couple for the
pacers yeah i actually do but i'm one of
those people like if you come in my
house like i don't want all basketball
memorabilia and stuff hanging up and
around and stuff like that now if i was
kareem i'll do a jabar probably or
michael jordan i probably wouldn't mind
seeing it but like me i'm like i'm good
i'd rather have some art on the wall
best crib you've ever been in
oh
i know the best one i want to go to
right now
rick ross so i've been to the house when
he vander holyfield when it was his home
and now what rick ross has done to the
house like i need to get down to the
to the forever mansion
you know but mike tyson had a great
house in vegas one time i got a chance
to go there after one of his fights
in vegas and i remember mike had uh
tigers
literally in the backyard he had big
screen i was like mike mike doing it big
so
i love this game so i love this game but
you know what rick ross's crib that's 56
000 square feet
it is
and he's usually on his tractor out
there clearing farmland or something
smoke
exactly is that an estate fit for a king
i need to get out there have you been to
shaq's place in orlando
i have not i heard though when you can't
go play golf without seeing it it's a
tourist attraction on the water there it
is right there
like in l.a when you get on one of those
tour buses
hey uh great great to talk to you again
and uh tell jacoby we said hello thank
you jalen
i will and thank you for being a legend
dan i have to ask you because i'm about
to do the show with jacob he brought me
a cayenne shot yeah is it cultural or
regional i don't take the shot all at
once but he does
do you yeah take it all at once yeah
it's just a healthy thing and a lot of
times you don't sip healthy you want to
get healthy over with
gotcha
it's cultural thank you appreciate the
love all right that's uh jaylen rose
we'll take a break we'll give you our
best and worst right after this